[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
JASON TITUS: Good
afternoon, everyone.
I'm Jason, and it's great to be
back here at I/O. This morning,
you got to hear all
about what we're doing
for our billions of users.
Now I'm excited to share what
we're doing for all of you--
the developers who are
solving everyday problems
in powerful ways.
Whether you're joining
us here at Shoreline
or watching via the
livestream or joining us
through one of 500 I/O
Extended events, welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
One of the reasons
I love my job is
that I get to meet with
developers from all
around the world and
hear what you're up to
and what you're
finding difficult.
It helps me understand
what we need
to do as Google to
make things easier,
as well as what we can do
better in our own products.
And one thing that
becomes instantly clear,
from Lagos to Warsaw to
Jakarta, is how important
the broader
development community
is in helping each
other figure out things
and solve problems together.
This kind of
pay-it-forward culture--
it's one of the great things
about working in this industry.
And I am constantly inspired
by the stories I hear out
of our Google Developer groups
and Google Developer experts
solving this [INAUDIBLE].
[APPLAUSE]
I see we have a few
of them here today.
Every year, with
their help, we're
able to reach more than
one million developers
through in-person events
across 140 countries.
And our Women
Techmakers program is
able to engage more than 100,000
women advance their careers
each year.
[APPLAUSE]
Our developer community
is truly important to us.
And all of this would not be
possible without their efforts.
It's also great that
in the last two years,
we have had the number of
Google Developer experts double.
These are amazing people,
like Rayan Al Zahab.
[APPLAUSE]
She both founded her local
Google Developer Group
and Women Techmakers Lebanon.
On top of that, she started
a web development training
program for Lebanese and
Syrian refugee girls.
We also have folks like Rebecca
Franks, an IoT and Android
expert in Johannesburg.
[APPLAUSE]
Out of her passion for
cultural preservation,
she works on an
open source app that
lets children read books in
their native African languages.
Google would not
be what it is today
if it weren't for developers
like Rayan, Rebecca,
and all of you.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
As you heard this morning,
Sundar was calling out--
the pace of AI innovation
is breathtaking.
A whole new set of
capabilities is going
to change the way we do things.
And what's really exciting
to me is that we're
at an inflection point.
AI used to be something that
only deep experts and PhDs
could use, and now it's
becoming accessible to everyone.
Let me show you what I mean.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- I would totally
describe myself
as an average high schooler.
I like hanging out with my
friends, watching movies,
getting my nails
done, and lately I've
been into machine learning using
convolutional neural networks.
I don't know why
you're laughing at me.
- Since childhood, she's always
wanted to know everything.
- Why is that?
How is that?
What does it do?
She just wants to be
always learning, moving,
doing different stuff.
- I haven't always been
into computer science,
but my mom grows rose
bushes in my front yard.
Every season, they'd get
disease, and then my mom
and I would have to diagnose it.
- Knowing Shaza, she wanted
to do something about it.
- I had the idea as
a potential thing
I could do for my research
class with Miss Son.
- Why anyone would sit around
their summer vacation teaching
a machine to identify plants--
not sure, but that was
what she wanted to do.
- I wanted to have a way people
could diagnose plant diseases
just by taking a photo of it.
And so that's when I started
looking into TensorFlow.
I'd watch different
tutorials and read blog posts
every night.
- Shaza took it upon herself
to do all the background
research necessary and then
start to ask, what can this
really do?
- PlantMD works when a user
takes a picture of the plant,
and it tells you
what plant it is
and whether it's
healthy or diseased.
And if it is diseased,
what disease it is.
- My first question
was, is it an app
that's only on your phone?
And she's like, no.
Somebody has downloaded
this app and using it.
That was, like, wow.
Something that I
just was so proud.
- I don't think you have
to be a super genius
to get into coding.
Really anyone can do it with
an idea and with perseverance.
I feel like open
source technology
and the wealth of
information on the internet
is empowering my generation.
I know that I can do
anything I put my mind to,
and so can anybody else.
[END PLAYBACK]
JASON TITUS: Amazing, right?
[APPLAUSE]
And we're delighted to
have Shaza and her family
here with us today.
[APPLAUSE]
So you can see why we're
so excited about bringing
technology like TensorFlow
and ML Kit to all of you.
As developers, you can drop
modules into your applications,
add a few lines of
code, and give them
intelligent new capabilities.
And this is only the
beginning of what is possible.
As a company, we're committed
to empowering developers
with the latest technology
to build things that matter.
And today, we'll
show you what we're
doing to make that easier.
So over the next
hour, we're going
to talk more about new
capabilities we're releasing,
as well as the improvements
we're making to the platforms
and tools you use every day.
So with that, let's
get started with Steph,
who's going to tell you
the latest on Android.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON: Android
is growing all over the world
with billions of devices, and
every month, billions of apps
downloaded.
Our developer community
is growing rapidly,
right alongside.
In China, India,
Brazil, the number
of developers using
our IDE almost
tripled in just two years.
With all this growth,
we feel a responsibility
to support this vast ecosystem.
And listen, if you feel
like your feedback drives
what we say here each
year, you are right,
like Kotlin last year.
[APPLAUSE]
Since we made it a
fully-supported language,
we've launched more and more
support, taking advantage
throughout Android.
Already, 35% of pro
developers use Kotlin.
That number grows every month.
And 95% of Kotlin users
say they're really happy.
More and more
Android development
is going towards Kotlin.
We are committed
for the long term.
And if you haven't
tried it, I would.
Just as your feedback
shaped investments so far,
like Play Console, Android
Studio, and Kotlin,
your feedback shaped
this year, too.
So let's cover
three things today.
First, distribution-- making
apps radically smaller
so you get more installs.
Second, development--
helping you
build faster, with better APIs.
And third, engagement-- bringing
users back more and more.
Let's go straight
into driving installs.
So Android is growing.
That's great.
App size is also growing,
and that is not great.
Apps are targeting more
people and more countries,
which means APKs have more
languages, more features.
The larger your app gets,
the less installs you get.
And most people think that's
an emerging markets issue,
but it's true in all countries.
So how can we make it easier
to build smaller apps?
Our best idea was hard for us.
It meant re-architecting our
entire app-serving stack.
But it was the
right way to do it.
Today, we are excited
to announce the new app
model for Android.
Using the Android App Bundle,
a new publishing format,
you can dramatically
reduce app size.
Apps need a lot of resources
to work on every device.
The bundle contains it
all, but modularized.
So when you download, Google
Play's new dynamic delivery
only delivers the code and
resources a specific device
needs.
Now, we've tested
this with many of you,
and we've seen huge savings.
LinkedIn saved 23%.
Twitter saved 35%.
[INAUDIBLE] saved 50%.
Now, if you're wondering, how
many devices does that work on?
The answer is 99%.
And that's because it's built on
long-standing platform concepts
like splits and multi-APK.
We also wanted this to be
almost no work for you.
And so I'd love to have you
see a demo from someone who's
been instrumental, along with
several teams who built this
together.
Please welcome Tor.
[APPLAUSE]
TOR NORBYE: Thank you, Steph.
So here I am, in Android
Studio, working on my app.
And I'd like to make it smaller.
So what I'll do is open
up our APK Analyzer.
And as you can see, most of the
download size is for resources.
We have several
large image folders
with different densities.
So this is an app
which can really
benefit from the new
dynamic delivery facility.
To use it, I don't have to
change a single line of code.
All I have to do is rebuild
my app as an app bundle.
So I'll invoke the
Generate APK dialog.
As you can see, we have a new
Android App Bundle option.
Next, I point to my
KeyStore, and I can also
tell it to export my
encryption key for Google Play.
This is what lets the Play
store break apart my app
and reassemble it
into smaller versions.
So then I'll trigger the build.
And once that's done, we can
take a look at the bundle
file we just created.
So as you can see, this
looks just like the APK files
that you already know and love,
but there's some extra metadata
here, which is what lets
the Play store do its magic.
So now, in the interest
of time, let's assume
that I've already uploaded
my app bundle and my sign
in key to the Play Console.
So then I land here.
We have a new page in the Play
Console called the App Bundle
Explorer.
Take a look at the big
number on the right.
This tells me that when
I publish this update,
I'm going to save nearly 29%
on downloads for my users.
And this page lets me drill
into just how that's possible.
So in short, creating Android
app bundles with Studio
is super easy, and
I hope you'll all
try it out and see similar gains
for yourselves and your users.
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON: And
all this is available now.
App bundles and dynamic
delivery are launching
for production use today.
[APPLAUSE]
Now, we're also working
to increase installs
in other ways.
At GDC, we announced
Google Play Instant.
So you can try a game
without having to install.
Now, games who have adopted
this have increased the number
of players by up to 20%.
Today, we're announcing that
this is available for all game
developers.
If you want to try
it right now, try
launching "Candy Crush Saga,"
because that launches today.
And to make development
easier, we're
also releasing a Unity
plugin and Cocos integration.
Now let's dive into
our second theme,
making app development easier.
Android's APIs could be easier.
One person said,
on Android, there's
six ways to do everything.
Last year, we launched
Architecture Components.
It was a testbed for
new ideas, starting
in top areas that you flagged,
like life cycles and data.
Today, so many top apps
use these in production.
And more than half
of you have said
you already use them or
plan to in the next year.
Today, we're announcing Android
Jetpack, the next generation
of Android APIs to accelerate
Android development.
Jetpack is a set of
libraries and tools.
We set the basic DNA by
including support library
and architecture components.
Jetpack brings these
together coherently
and adds even more new
libraries, work management,
navigation, paging, slices,
and Kotlin extensions
across everything.
All libraries are
backwards-compatible,
which means they work
on 95% of devices.
So it's been a pain to
schedule background tasks.
Now, with Work Manager, you
get a single, easy-to-use API
that works nearly everywhere.
And Jetpack is all
about concise APIs.
Those of you who've
tried it say you're
writing up to 1/3 less code.
Jetpack and Kotlin
are intentionally
designed to work
together so you write
only the code you need for a
pleasant reading and writing
experience.
And Jetpack saves time by
embodying opinions about what
we found works best for Android
development, like RxJava
or material design.
Jetpack's APIs are
integrated with the IDE, too.
For instance, Android Studio
now includes a Navigation Editor
which works with the library.
So you can visualize
your app flow,
almost like you're
sketching on a whiteboard.
You can add new screens,
position them in your flow.
And under the covers,
we'll help you
manage the back stack,
conditional flows until you
get it just right.
Overall--
[APPLAUSE]
--IDE tools, we think,
are great helpers
to make development fast.
That's why everything you've
seen bundles using Jetpack
comes with Studio support.
And the team also works on
making everyday tasks faster.
You told us, work on
emulator boot time,
and I'd like you to see it now.
TOR NORBYE: All
right, so first, let
me show you how quickly
our emulator can start now.
Ready, set, go.
As you can see,
it's nearly instant.
[APPLAUSE]
I was not cheating.
It was not running
in the background.
The reason it's so fast is
that we support snapshots.
So we store the full
state of the emulator
into a file that we can
then load back quickly.
And you can create these
snapshots yourself.
So now I'm going to
bring back a snapshot
I took in the middle of a
complex OpenGL 3D stress test.
Ready, set, go.
So you can see it's
about two seconds,
and it's up and running.
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON: There
are more speed enhancements.
We added an energy profiler,
integrated an improved system
trace.
There's a C++ profiler now.
We promoted D8
compiler to stable
after testing it on our
own Android platform, which
means smaller, faster
binaries by default.
And we added an ADB Connection
Assistant to fix, hey, why
can't I connect to that device?
So that's Android development--
faster and easier.
We hope you try Android Studio
and Jetpack previews today,
including all the alpha
stage new libraries.
Jetpack is just a
beginning for us.
We are testing so
many more new ideas,
and we hope you watch for
them in the months ahead.
OK, so once your app is
built, it's installed,
we want to get
users coming back.
The slices Dave showed
are a cool new way
to drive reengagement.
We wanted these to
be easy to build.
So you'll find templates
that are rich and flexible
so you can compose.
You can start with
something simple,
like a set of rows or grids.
Then you can add content,
like text and images.
But not just static
content, you can also
house real-time data
and rich controls.
And once you get the pieces
together in a good setup,
you can add the code to
make slices interactive,
like pause a song or
go to the next one.
So then you end up with this
cool mini-snippet of your app.
And because it's Jetpack,
slices work on 95% of devices,
showing the power of building
new features in a Jetpack
world.
This is also ready for
everyone here to try today.
Your slices will start showing
up in Search this summer,
timed with the P launch, and
Assistant later this year.
So that's a quick tour of
some of the biggest new areas
of investment for Android
and how your feedback
has been shaping the landscape.
Now let's switch gears and
talk about cool devices.
At CES this year, we announced
that Lenovo, Harman, LG,
and iHome are all building
consumer products powered
by Android Things--
a powerful platform for
developing IoT products.
This week, Android
Things graduates
from developer preview to
1.0, ready for everyone
to build commercial devices.
And everyone here at I/O will
get a free Android Things
developer kit.
[APPLAUSE]
If you want to get it first,
join the scavenger hunt today,
or everyone here can
pick one up tomorrow.
As we continue to expand to
more devices and more surfaces,
our team and the
Assistant team have
been working closely together.
To hear more, please
welcome Brad Abrams.
[APPLAUSE]
BRAD ABRAMS: Awesome.
Thanks, Steph.
This morning, you heard how the
Assistant is becoming even more
conversational and visual,
helping users get things done,
save time, and be more present.
And developers like you have
been a big part of the story,
making the Assistant more useful
across 500 million devices.
DoorDash, Fitbit, Todoist,
Starbucks, Disney,
and many, many others
are engaging with users
through Actions that they build.
And smart home OEMs like GE,
Arlo, Xiaomi, and Logitech
have made more
than 5,000 devices
that work with the Assistant.
In total, the
Google Assistant is
ready to help with over one
million Actions built by Google
and all of you.
And the platform's momentum
has been growing every day.
It's now available across 16
languages and multiple devices,
including phones, smart
speakers, TVs, cars, watches,
headphones, and whole
new categories of devices
like smart displays,
which are coming in July.
And we're delighted to
see that many of you
are starting to test the waters
with this new, emerging era
of conversational computing.
In fact, over half
a million developers
are learning and building with
Dialogflow, our conversation
development tool.
Today, I'm excited
to share how we're
making it even easier for app
developers and web developers
to get started with
the Google Assistant.
You can think of your
Assistant Action as a companion
experience to your main
property that users
can access from a smart
speaker, even in the car--
wherever they're not using
their phone or laptop.
And if you want to personalize
that Action for users,
account linking lets
you easily share
state between your
app and your Action.
And now, with seamless
digital subscriptions,
your users can enjoy the
content and digital goods
they purchased in
your Android app
directly in your
Assistant Action.
Take "The Economist,"
for example.
Because I'm a premium
subscriber in their app,
I can now enjoy that
same premium content
on any Assistant-enabled device.
But of course, creating
engaging actions
doesn't end with
digital subscriptions.
As you saw in the
demos this morning,
the Assistant is becoming a
canvas that blends conversation
with rich visual interactions
for the phone and other devices
like smart displays.
And starting today,
you can deeply
customize the appearance
of your Action.
You saw a glimpse of what
was possible earlier today
with demos from
Tasty and Starbucks,
but let me show you another one.
Check out the game "King for a
Day" here on a smart display.
It looks beautiful here, on
the phone, and on the TV.
Of course, once you build
an Action for the Assistant,
you want to get lots of people
engaged with that experience.
And for that, I've got
three things to share.
First, we're making
it even easier
for you to promote your
Action with something
new we call Action Links.
These are hyperlinks
that you can
use from anywhere that point
directly into your Action.
Let me give you an example.
Headspace has built
a great experience
for the Google Assistant that
can help people meditate.
Now, when they have
some new content,
they might share a
blog post about it.
This post contains an Action
Link right there at the bottom.
And that special link triggers
the Headspace Action directly
in the Google Assistant.
If you've already
built an Action
and you want to spread
the word, starting today,
you can visit the Action Console
to find your shareable Action
Link.
OK, so now that you've
acquired some new users,
you want to engage them.
And for this, we've got
Action Notifications.
Once users opt in,
Action Notifications
gives you a way to connect
with them about new features
and content.
These notifications
work on the phone,
even if users don't have
your Android app installed.
And now, with
cross-surface notifications
coming to the
Assistant, you'll be
able to reengage with
your users on speakers,
smart displays, and other
Assistant-enabled devices.
But to consistently
reengage with users,
you need to become part
of their daily habits.
And for that, the Assistant
supports routines.
This is the ability to
execute multiple actions
with a single command for things
like waking up in the morning,
getting to work, or
many other daily tasks.
And now, with
Routine Suggestions,
after somebody engages
with your Action,
you can prompt them to add
your Action to their routine
with just a couple of taps.
So for example, on my
way to work each morning,
my Assistant can tell
me how to beat traffic,
and it can also help me order
my Americano from Starbucks.
We're excited to see how Action
Links, Action Notifications,
and Routine Suggestions will
help you drive engagement.
But the broader challenge
of helping people
connect with the right
Action is reminiscent
of the early days of the web.
Over the past 20
years, we've built up
a lot of experience
in connecting people
with the right information,
services, and content.
And we're putting
that expertise to work
in the Google Assistant.
For example, when somebody
says, hey, Google, let's
start a maps quiz, the
Assistant should immediately
suggest relevant games.
For that to happen,
we need to understand
the user's basic intent.
And that's hard,
because there are
thousands of ways that users
could ask to play a game.
To handle this complexity,
we're beginning
to map all the
ways that users can
ask for things into a
taxonomy of built-in intents.
Today, we're making the first
set of those intents available.
And with these, you'll be able
to give the Assistant a deeper
understanding of what
your Action can do.
We'll be rolling out
hundreds of built-in intents
in the coming months.
So with that, I'm excited
to see how you all
extend your experiences to the
Google Assistant, how you'll
build rich, immersive
interactions, and create
consistent engagement
for your users.
To learn more and get started
building Actions today,
visit actions.google.com.
And with that, let me introduce
Tal, who will tell you
about the web platform.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
TAL OPPENHEIMER: Thanks, Brad.
I don't think it's
an exaggeration
to say that the
web is the world's
most critical
resource for ensuring
the free flow of information.
The web is a fundamentally
open and independent platform.
So for developers,
the web makes it
possible to reach users around
the world on almost any device.
And for users, the web
provides a truly frictionless
experience.
You tap on a link
and load a page.
And these properties
have allowed the web
to reach a massive scale,
with over five billion devices
accessing the web each month.
And here at Google, from
the very earliest days
of page rank to building
our very own browser,
we've been deeply invested
in the continued growth
and reach of the web.
And as part of this,
we have two main goals.
First, to make the
web platform itself
more powerful and more capable.
And second, to build
tools to help you easily
take advantage of this power.
Over the past few
years on Chrome,
we've worked alongside
other browsers
to add capabilities
to the platform
to support new web
experiences we've been calling
Progressive Web Apps, or PWAs.
PWAs are websites that take
advantage of modern web
platform APIs to build
experiences that can do things
like work while
the user's offline,
send push notifications, or be
added directly to a user's home
screen.
And universally, businesses
that have built PWAs
have seen incredible results.
Take Instagram.
Instagram launched
their PWA last year
to increase their reach to
users with low-end devices.
And they were able to double the
retention of their web users.
Times Internet
has been launching
PWAs across their
products and saw
an 87% increase in time spent
per user for their "Economic
Times" PWA.
And when the Starbucks
team rolled out their PWA,
they doubled their daily
and monthly active users
on their website.
And because the web adapts
seamlessly to different devices
and platforms, their
mobile PWA also
worked well for their
desktop web audience.
In fact, they found
that the number
of orders placed on
the desktop version
has grown to be about equal
to the number of orders
placed on their mobile version.
And it's not just
these businesses.
Across sites that
advertise with Google,
we see an average
mobile conversion rate
boost of 20% when the
site switches to a PWA.
And we also build many
of our own products
here at Google as PWAs.
Google Maps launched a
new mobile PWA tailored
to provide a fast and
data-conscious experience,
and Google.com itself is a PWA.
It loads 50% less
JavaScript over the network
and can support features
like retrying search queries
if you're offline.
And investing in a PWA today
goes further than ever.
Chrome OS now provides
native support
for PWAs, allowing them
to be installed and run
fully integrated and in
their own standalone window.
And we're incredibly
excited that Service Worker,
the underlying new API
that makes PWAs possible,
is now supported on
all major browsers,
including recently Edge
on Windows and Safari
on both desktop and mobile.
This is probably the most
important leap forward
for the web in the last decade.
So PWAs have fundamentally
changed what the web can do.
But that's only part of it.
WebAssembly enables websites
to run high-performance,
low-level code written in
languages like C and C++,
and it has broad support
across browsers and devices.
And because this code has
access to all of the web's APIs,
WebAssembly enables a
new class of content
to run on the web platform.
As just one example, the
AutoCAD team took a 35-year-old
codebase-- that's older
than the web itself--
and were able to compile
it to run directly
inside a browser
using WebAssembly.
So now all of the power of
AutoCAD is just a link away.
So the web platform's
been gaining all these
great new capabilities,
but we want
to make sure it's easy for
you to take advantage of them.
So we've been working
on the tools to help.
Lighthouse is a feature of
Chrome's built-in DevTools
that analyzes your site and
gives you clear guidance
on how you can improve
your user's experience.
Half a million developers
are running Lighthouse
against their site or as part
of their continuous integration
process, to help avoid
performance regressions,
or even to keep an eye
on the competition.
And today, we're launching
Lighthouse 3.0, which
makes Lighthouse's performance
metrics even more precise
and its guidance
even more actionable.
So Lighthouse helps
you understand
how you can upgrade
your site, but we don't
want to just give you advice.
We want to give you
the tools to help
make sure any new
sites you build
are high quality by default.
We started the AMP Project
two years ago to
help make building
fast web pages much easier.
And I'm happy to share that AMP
is evolving in some big ways.
We're expanding the kinds of
things you can do with AMP.
We've added a bunch of
features that support
critical e-commerce
experience in AMP,
like search auto-complete,
a full-featured date picker,
and soon, infinite
scrolling lists.
And businesses are
seeing the benefits.
As just one example, Overstock
saw a 36% increase in revenue
on their AMP pages.
And we've introduced AMP
Stories, an easy-to-use format
for creating immersive
stories on the mobile web.
Now, all AMP content
benefits from
a fast, free,
privacy-preserving cache
that optimizes page loads.
But they've had these
Google.com URLs.
So we're fixing that with a new
standard called web packaging.
This is also the first step
towards our ultimate goal
for any fast,
responsive web content--
to be able to take advantage
of all of the benefits of AMP.
And today, we're
announcing a new way
to take advantage of
all of these tools.
We introduced Chrome OS
almost seven years ago
to showcase the best
of the web and make
computing accessible to all.
Chromebooks grew
50% this past year,
both units sold and
28-day active users.
And we've expanded to
tablets and attachables.
But it's not just about
access to technology.
It's also about
access to create it.
And that's why we're expanding
Chrome OS to support developers
with the ability to securely
run Linux apps on Chrome OS.
[APPLAUSE]
So this means that many of
your favorite tools, editors,
and IDEs now work
on Chromebooks.
So starting with the Dev
channel on Pixelbooks,
you can now build for the
web on a platform built
around the web.
And soon, you'll
even be able to run
Android Studio on Chrome OS.
[APPLAUSE]
So all in all, it's an
incredibly exciting time
to be a web developer.
Businesses around the
world are consistently
seeing substantial
returns from deeply
investing in their
web experience
by building
progressive web apps.
And the reach of these PWAs
is now truly everywhere,
with support across
every major browser.
And it's easier than ever to
build great web experiences
with tools like
Lighthouse and AMP
and so many more of our
web developer products
that you'll hear
about throughout I/O.
The web platform is
light years ahead
of where it was in
Google's early days,
and it remains as core
as ever to our mission.
We're excited about the host
of new use cases made possible
by today's modern web,
so be sure to check out
the web platform state
of the union talk
later today to learn more.
And now, please
join me in welcoming
Rich to talk about updates
to Material Design.
[APPLAUSE]
RICH FULCHER: Thanks, Tal.
I'm going to talk about
Material Design's new approach
to customizing our apps, and
share some of the new tools
and resources we've created.
We introduced Material
Design in 2014
as a system for creating
bold, beautiful,
and consistent digital
products across platforms.
We were responding
to the desire that we
heard from you and
developers around the world
for clear design
guidance, for advice
that would make the
experiences you create better
for your users.
Material has become
the design foundation
for all Google products.
And you've taken it and launched
it into millions of apps.
But we've heard two
sentiments especially clearly
after hundreds of design
reviews with product teams
and developers.
First, that you didn't
always see Material
as flexible enough, that
products from different brands
looked too similar.
And second, that our
engineering support for Material
needed to be stronger so that
you could more easily realize
your design vision.
Our goal has always been to
provide more than just a design
blueprint.
We are committed to
delivering resources, tools,
and engineering components
to make it easier for product
teams to work
together seamlessly
from design to development so
that you can deliver customized
experiences for your users.
That's why we're
proud to announce
Material Theming, a major update
to the Material Design system.
With Material Theming, we're
delivering a truly unified
and adaptable design system.
It enables you to express
your brand's unique identity
using color, using type,
and shape consistently
across your product.
Material Theming retains
the consistent guidance
from Material and expands on it.
Let's take a look.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- What if it was possible
to design and build better
so your ideas could scale from
a single sheet to a system?
With Material, you can
apply color dynamically
so that every touch enhances
the character of your design.
Typography is adaptable
so you can express more
by customizing for
style and legibility.
Craft an experience that's
responsive across device
and platform.
Streamline collaboration with
tools and open source code,
making it easy to express
your brand's unique identity,
balancing form and function
down to every last detail.
Material Design
isn't a single style.
It's an adaptable design system
inspired by paper and ink
and engineered so you can build
beautiful, usable products
faster.
What will you make?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
RICH FULCHER: Material
Theming puts you in charge.
When you make just a few
decisions about aspects
like color or type,
for example, we'll
apply those throughout
your design.
You'll see options
for customization
across our design guidelines.
And we've added hundreds
of new examples.
All still Material, but
reflecting a much wider range
of products and styles.
When you see something
you like, you
can use our handy
redline viewer to check
the dimensions, padding, and
even the hex color values.
Today, we're also
releasing two new tools
to make it faster to go from
design to implementation.
First, Material Theme Editor.
This plugin for the
popular application Sketch
helps designers
create and customize
a unique Material theme.
Change one theme value, and
it cascades across the design.
Then that work can be shared
easily using Material Gallery.
This is the tool used by
product teams at Google
to review and comment
on design iterations,
and it's now
available to everyone.
When it's time to build, you
can see automatic redlines.
You can identify exactly
which component is being used
and how it's been customized.
But we need to make all of
this easier not just to design,
but to realize in code.
So our open source
Material Design components
for Android, iOS, the
web, and Flutter--
all with Material Theming--
are available today.
[APPLAUSE]
These are the same
components we use
at Google to build our apps.
And just as Google creates a
custom Material theme that best
reflects our brand in products--
starting with the new Gmail
for the web--
you can use these
same components
to create an experience and a
theme that is right for you.
More Material components and
Material Theming customizations
will be coming soon,
so keep an eye out.
We'll be launching regularly.
And we'll keep
listening, so please
keep the feedback coming.
Material Theming--
a new approach
to customizing your apps powered
by open source components,
new tools, and design
guidance-- all available today.
To make Material yours,
get started at material.io.
And now, here's Jia to
talk about progress in AI.
[APPLAUSE]
JIA LI: Thanks, Rich.
Hi, everyone.
At Google, we believe
developers are driving
the real-world impact of AI.
Of course, we understand
how complex this can be.
Machine learning is a
challenge in any environment,
but today's developers often
target multiple platforms
and devices.
We also have to juggle
issues like processing power,
bandwidth, latency,
and battery life.
That's why we're committed
to making AI easier
to use, no matter what
platform you are on.
This begins in the
Cloud, which makes
machine learning accessible to
customers in every industry.
We believe success
in AI should be
determined by your imagination,
not your infrastructure.
We invest the best technology
to power Google's products,
and Google Cloud is making these
resources available to you.
For example, our Cloud
TPUs are widely available
in public beta, making
machine learning more
affordable than ever before.
Until recently, training
a model to a high accuracy
on the ImageNet data set
cost thousands of dollars.
But in a Stanford
benchmark contest,
our TPUs reached the same
level for less than $50.
Cloud TPUs are now available to
everyone, and getting started
is as simple as
following this link.
And this morning, we announced
our new third generation TPU,
demonstrating our ongoing
commitment to AI hardware.
The Cloud also lets us
share our best technology
through a growing range
of machine learning APIs.
Our latest is Cloud
text-to-speech.
Based on DeepMind's
WaveNet, the same technology
behind the voices in
the Google Assistants,
it generates speech with 32
voices in multiple languages
and variants.
In just a few lines of
code, your application
can realistically
speak to your users
across many platforms
and devices.
For more sophisticated
interaction with your users,
text-to-speech can be paired
with Dialogflow Enterprise
Edition.
Dialogflow makes it easy to
build a conversational agent,
even with no prior experience.
It understands the
intent and context
of what a user says and
generates accurate responses,
whether you are
shopping for clothes
or scheduling your bike repair.
Finally, Cloud AI is
always exploring new ways
to put more power in
the hands of developers.
This effort continues
with Cloud AutoML,
which automates the creation
of machine learning models.
Our first
widely-available release
will be AutoML
Vision, which makes
it possible to recognize
images unique to your vocation
without writing any code.
You provide the
training examples,
and AutoML does the rest.
Our alpha users are
already accomplishing
a lot with AutoML, from
identifying poisonous spiders
to helping the blind
better understand images.
But Vision is just
the beginning.
We're looking forward
to bringing AutoML
to more machine learning
tasks very soon.
To learn more about
all Cloud AI products,
including AutoML early
adoption, please visit our site.
But Cloud AI technology
isn't the only thing
that we're pushing
in new directions.
TensorFlow has become
a standard in machine
learning since we open
sourced it two years ago,
with 13 million downloads.
Now we're focusing on
bringing it to new platforms.
We recently announced
TensorFlow.js,
which brings machine learning
to millions of web developers
through JavaScript.
New models can be created
right in the browser,
or on the server
side through Node.js.
While models trained offline
can be imported, and run
with WebGL acceleration.
Of course, there is a big
world beyond the browser.
We also introduced
TensorFlow Lite last year,
which brings machine
learning to Edge devices,
including Android
and iOS phones.
This allows offline
processing with low latency
and ensures sensitive data
never leaves the device.
TensorFlow Lite also supports
hardware like the Raspberry Pi,
so smart devices like the AIY
Project Vision and Voice Kits
can leverage it as well.
As Dave announced
earlier this morning,
we've released ML Kit
in beta, an SDK that
brings Google's machine
learning capabilities
to mobile developers
through Firebase.
The same technology
that has powered
Google's own experiences,
like text recognition
in Google Translate and
Smart Reply in Gmail,
will be available to
power your own apps.
Our vision for AI at Google is
turning the latest technology
into products that make
better life for everyone.
But we cannot do this without
creative developers like you.
Together, we can
bring AI to the world.
To talk more about how Google is
supporting mobile development,
let me introduce Francis Ma.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
FRANCIS MA: Thank you, Jia.
Our mission for Firebase is to
help mobile app teams succeed
by providing a
platform to help you
solve key problems across
the lifecycle of your app--
from building your app
to improving app quality
to growing your business.
We've come a long way
since we expanded Firebase
two years ago from
a real-time database
to a broad app
development platform.
And it's so exciting
to see there
are now over 1.2
million apps actively
using Firebase every
month, including
many of the top Android and iOS
apps like Pandora, Pinterest,
and Flipkart.
We appreciate so many of you
are trusting us with your apps,
whether you're a sole developer
or working in large teams.
We're committed to helping
developers at companies
of all sizes to succeed.
Now, one of our key
goals is to help
you take care of the critical,
but sometimes less glamorous
parts of app development so you
can focus more on your users
and build cool stuff.
As an example, we've
worked hard to ensure
we're ready to meet
your compliance
needs with many privacy
and security standards,
as well as with
the upcoming GDPR.
We are also continuing
to expand the platform
to further simplify everyday
developer challenges.
A little over a year
ago, the Fabric team
joined forces with us to bring
the best of our platforms
together.
And we've made a lot
of progress since then.
In the last couple
of months, we've
brought Crashlytics, Fabric's
flagship crash reporter,
into Firebase.
And we've improved
it by integrating it
with Google Analytics so
you can see what users
did in your app that led
up to a crash for much
easier diagnosis.
With the combination of
Crashlytics, performance
monitoring, and
Google Analytics,
Firebase is not just a platform
to help you build your app's
infrastructure, but also to
help you better understand
and improve your app.
Another major set
of advancements
we've been making to
Firebase over the last year
is introducing machine
learning to the platform.
A few months ago, we
took our first step
with the release of
Firebase Predictions.
Predictions applies ML
to your analytics data
and predicts the future
behavior of your users
so you can take proactive
actions to optimize your app.
For example, you can lower
the difficulty of your game
for users who are likely
to abandon it, or send
special offers to users
who are likely to spend.
And you can also run A/B
tests with different setup
to see which of
these performed best.
So Predictions
was the first step
that we took to bring the power
of Google's ML to work for you.
And today, we're
taking our second step
with the release of
ML Kit in public beta.
ML Kit-- we're bringing
together Google's machine
learning technologies
from across Google
and making that available
to every mobile developer
working on Android and iOS.
ML Kit provides five
out-of-the-box APIs,
like image labeling
and text recognition,
and these APIs can run on-device
for low latency processing
or in the Cloud for
higher levels of accuracy.
You can also bring your own
custom TensorFlow Lite model
if you have more specific needs.
So let's talk through
an example of how
ML Kit can be used in an app.
Now, I'm a dad of two.
And my young kids are always
so curious about the world
around them.
And I thought it'd be
fun to build an app
where we can take pictures
and identify objects in them.
And by using ML Kit's
on-device image labeling API,
it's easy for me to apply ML
to identify different objects--
it's a dog, a tree, or a bridge.
Now, as many of you are aware,
one of the key challenges
of building for mobile is
having a low latency response
and assurance that
it can work even
without a network connection.
And by using ML
Kit's on-device API,
I can be assured that
image labeling will work,
even if I'm out on a remote hike
with no network connectivity.
So on-device APIs are great
for low latency processing,
but there are
other times where I
want to optimize for
highest accuracy possible.
For example, when
identifying landmarks,
I want my kids to know this is
the Golden Gate Bridge and not
just any bridge.
And ML Kit's Cloud-powered
APIs give me that.
They have a much higher
level of accuracy
and can be easily integrated
right from my app client code.
Then there are other situations
where you may have more
specific needs than what the
out-of-the-box APIs can cover.
And for those times, you'd
want to bring your own custom
ML models.
Now, as mobile developers,
we know how important
it is to keep your
app binary small
and be able to iterate on
the experience rapidly.
With ML Kit, you can
upload your TensorFlow Lite
model and [? surf ?]
that through Google's
global infrastructure.
Your app can dynamically
retrieve these models
and evaluate them on-device.
This means you don't need to
bundle the model with your app
binary, and you
can also update it
without re-publishing
your entire app.
And since ML Kit is
available through Firebase,
it's easy for you to take
advantage of the broader
Firebase platform--
for example, experimenting
with different ML models
using A/B testing, or
storing your image labels
with Cloud Firestore, or
measuring processing latency
with performance
monitoring, or understanding
the impact on user engagement
with Google Analytics.
We are so excited
about the possibilities
that machine learning
unlocks, whether you
want to supercharge your
growth or build amazing user
experiences.
We want to harness
Google's advances
to help you build
and grow your app.
And with that, I'd like to
turn it over to Nathan Martz
to talk about another area
of exciting advancements
in mobile computing--
augmented reality.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
NATHAN MARTZ: Hey, everybody.
I got to say, it is incredibly
exciting to be here today.
At Google, we believe that
augmented reality represents
one of the most exciting
advances in mobile computing
today.
By enabling our devices to
see and sense the world much
like we do, AR allows us to
interact with digital content
and information in the context
of the real world, which
is exactly where it's often
the most useful and accessible.
And as our phones learn to
see the world in new ways,
they unlock new possibilities
for the kinds of experiences
that developers can create.
That's why, just
three months ago, we
launched ARCore, our platform
for building augmented reality
experiences, to
allow you to take
advantage of this
incredible new technology.
And we've already seen
some amazing apps.
For example, you can
now create a floor plan
just by walking
around your home.
You can visualize
the intricacies
of the human nervous
system at real-world scale.
Or if you like, transform
your dining room table
into the home of your
next virtual pet.
And as you've been
building, we've
been learning and
listening to your feedback.
Today, we're rolling
out a major update
to ARCore to help you create
even richer, more immersive
and interactive experiences.
First, we know that
creating a 3D app
can be challenging,
especially when you
have to write directly to
lower-level APIs like OpenGL.
That's why we've created
Sceneform, a brand new 3D
framework that makes it
easy for Java developers
to create ARCore applications.
And the thing is,
Sceneform is not just
for people creating
apps from scratch.
Its design actually
makes it really easy
to quickly add ARCore
features to apps
that you've already released.
Under the hood,
the Sceneform SDK
includes an expressive API,
a powerful, physically-based
renderer, and seamless
support for 3D assets
inside of Android Studio.
Best of all, Sceneform
is optimized for mobile,
architected from the ground-up
with performance, memory,
and binary size in mind.
So we also know that
sometimes as a developer,
you want to build
an AR app that can
react to the specific physical
objects in the real world.
That's why today we're
introducing Augmented Images,
a new capability in ARCore that
makes it possible to attach
AR content and experiences
to the physical images
in the real world.
And Augmented
Images doesn't just
detect the presence
of a picture.
It can actually compute
the precise 3D orientation
of that image in real time.
So now you can use Augmented
Images to do things
like bring a textbook to life,
create new forms of artwork.
You can even see what's inside
the toy box before you open it.
Finally, though, we
know that if we truly
want our computers to
work more like we do,
they need to involve not
just the things in our world,
but the people in our lives.
Fundamentally, our time
here is spent with family
and friends and colleagues.
We collaborate, we create, we
share experiences together.
That's why we believe that
every incredible thing that you
can do by yourself
in AR today, you
should be able to do
together with someone else.
It makes me very proud to
announce the next major step
in how our phones
see and understand
the world, a new
capability in ARCore
that we call Cloud Anchors.
With Cloud Anchors, we
actually allow multiple devices
to generate--
thank you-- a shared,
synchronized understanding
of the world so that multiple
phones can see and interact
with the exact same digital
content in the same place
at the same time.
And this allows
you, as a developer,
to create applications that
are collaborative and creative,
multi-user and multiplayer.
To show you exactly
what I mean, we actually
integrated Cloud
Anchor support into
our experimental, open source,
AR drawing app "Just a Line."
Let's take a look.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
We know that Cloud Anchors will
enable many new kinds of AR
experiences.
AR experiences that
combine the power
of your device, your creativity,
and the people around you.
But because these
experiences are so powerful,
we believe that they
should work regardless
of the kind of phone you own.
That's why I'm
very excited to say
that we're making
ARCore's Cloud Anchors
available on both
Android and iOS devices.
[APPLAUSE]
It's pretty awesome.
So everything that I've
just talked about today,
from Sceneform to
Augmented Images to Cloud
Anchors and more, is available
for you to use right now.
You can learn more about that
and start creating your own
ARCore-powered app by going
to developers.google.com/ar.
And with that, I'm going
to hand it back to Jason
to wrap things up.
Thank you all very
much for your time.
[APPLAUSE]
JASON TITUS: Thanks, Nathan.
Hopefully you can
see from our talks
today that we're
committed to meet you
where you are, no matter what
platform you're building on,
and help you take advantage
of the latest innovations,
from machine learning
to augmented reality.
And much of what
you heard of today
is built on top of
our Cloud technology.
This includes powerful APIs
around machine learning,
smarter data analytics
with BigQuery,
and a focus on low latency
and high reliability.
And whenever possible,
we try and take things
out as open source, like
Kubernetes and TensorFlow,
so they can be broadly
adopted and openly evolved
across the industry.
With our Cloud technology,
we're taking the lessons
we've learned building
large-scale software
and bringing them to you.
So I/O, this year,
is bigger than ever.
We've got some great content
lined up for the next few days.
And you'll see we're doing
something new this year--
inspiration talks.
They take a broader look at how
the technology that you build
affects the world around us.
So we cover topics like building
for a better tech-life balance,
the future of
computing, and using
AI to transform health care.
We all have a responsibility
for what we build
as well as the people
that we build for,
so I hope you have a
chance to check these out.
And one of my favorite
parts about having
I/O so close to
campus is that we're
able to bring in more
than 2,000 Googlers who
built these products.
They're here not
only to help you,
but more importantly,
to get your feedback
on what we can do better.
My hope for this conference
is that each of you
walks away feeling that
you can do something
that you couldn't do
before, and that you're
able to use that knowledge
to build things that matter.
Thank you very much, and
have a great Google I/O.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]